en este vídeo vamos a mostrar más
ejemplos para asegurarnos de que se
entiende cómo se deben contabilizar
diversas cosas cuando calculamos el pib
mediante el enfoque de gasto ya hemos
mencionado en otros vídeos que existen
distintas maneras de calcular el pib
pero con el enfoque de gasto puedes
desglosar lo en sus diversos componentes
el consumo de los hogares más las
inversiones de las empresas más los
gastos del gobierno en bienes y
servicios más las exportaciones netas
una vez explicado esto pausa el vídeo
para examinar estos elementos y pensar
en qué efecto puede tener cada uno sobre
el pib si lo abordamos a través del
enfoque de gasto y cómo podemos
contabilizar lo en estas distintas
categorías muy bien ahora resolvamos
esto juntos en el primer caso se nos
dice que fort paga un millón de dólares
por un robot fabricado en eeuu para su
fábrica en california en este caso
tenemos una empresa ford que realiza una
inversión en capital físico en la
mayoría de los casos sobre todo si vas a
hacer una prueba
o un examen a p inversión quiere decir
empresas que emplean dinero en capital
físico o capital productivo aunque
también pueden invertir en capital
intelectual como programas informáticos
pero aquí queda claro que ford está
comprando un robot fabricado en estados
unidos y este robot es capital físico
porque va a ayudar a ford a fabricar más
automóviles y camiones entonces queda
claro que esto va a incrementar el pib
el pib aumenta en un millón de dólares
por esta razón y vamos a contabilizar
este millón como una inversión por lo
tanto podemos decir que la inversión
aumenta en un millón de dólares o que la
razón por la que sumamos un millón de
dólares al pib de eeuu es porque una
empresa estadounidense invirtió esa
cantidad pasemos al siguiente caso una
empresa de alquiler de coches
estadounidense gasta un millón de
dólares para comprar 30 coches ford
nuevos fabricados en eeuu pausa el vídeo
y reflexiona sobre esto
se trata de un escenario muy parecido
una empresa estadounidense que invierte
en capital físico la empresa compra 30
coches nuevos para rentarlos y obtener
un beneficio futuro entonces otra vez
sería lo mismo en el primer caso el pib
aumentó en un millón porque se invirtió
un millón también en este caso el pib
aumenta en un millón de dólares porque
la inversión fue de un millón de dólares
veamos ahora el tercer caso una empresa
de alquiler de coches estadounidense
gasta un millón de dólares para comprar
30 coches toyota nuevos fabricados en
japón cuál es la diferencia en este caso
de nuevo tenemos una empresa
estadounidense que invierte un millón de
dólares en capital físico entonces la
inversión debería aumentar en un millón
de dólares pero no se está invirtiendo
en productos fabricados en eeuu se está
invirtiendo en productos fabricados en
japón en este caso particular la
inversión sería contrarrestada por las
exportaciones netas aquí se están
importando productos por un valor de un
millón de dólares
que las exportaciones netas disminuyen
en un millón de dólares una importación
de un millón de dólares es lo mismo que
una exportación neta de menos un millón
de dólares por esta razón esta inversión
no tendrá ningún impacto sobre el pib
podemos usar la intuición para llegar a
esta conclusión porque no hay que
olvidar que el pib mide cuánto se
produce en un país y en este caso la
empresa de alquiler de coches
estadounidense está invirtiendo en algo
producido en otro país no en eeuu veamos
el siguiente caso una empresa de
alquiler de coches japonesa gasta un
millón de dólares para comprar 30 coches
ford nuevos fabricados en eeuu
esta es una situación simétricamente
opuesta a la anterior aquí la inversión
no va a aumentar porque se trata de una
empresa de alquiler de coches japonesa y
estamos calculando el pib de eeuu pero
debido a que eeuu está exportando esos
30 coches nuevos el millón de dólares se
suma a las exportaciones netas
entonces en este caso las exportaciones
netas vamos a escribirlo las
exportaciones netas aumentan en un
millón de dólares y debido a que las
millón de dólares y no hay ningún otro
impacto el pib aumenta en un millón de
dólares esto tiene lógica porque eeuu
fabricó los coches por un valor de un
millón de dólares y los está exportando
así que se contabilizan aquí debido a
ello el pib de eeuu es un millón de
dólares más alto
el siguiente caso es interesante tú
compras 100 mil dólares en acciones de
ibm que crees que es esto
pausa el vídeo y piénsalo en el lenguaje
cotidiano podrías decir invertir 100 mil
dólares en acciones de ibm pero yo
pertenezco a un hogar entonces cómo
funciona esto bueno pues resulta que no
afecta ninguno de estos componentes
porque se supone que le estás comprando
esos 100 mil dólares en acciones de ibm
a otra persona no es que se esté
fabricando algo en el país se trata de
otro tipo de productividad y aunque en
el lenguaje cotidiano a veces pensemos
en esto como una inversión en realidad
no tiene ningún impacto en estos
componentes vamos a escribirlo ningún
impacto quiero recalcar que a veces
asociamos la palabra inversión con cosas
como la compra de acciones pero para el
pib una inversión es cuando una empresa
compra algún tipo de capital que le
producirá un beneficio futuro y le
ayudará a mejorar las cosas con
frecuencia se trata de capital físico
pero también pueden ser cosas como
programas informáticos o algún otro tipo
de capital
en el caso siguiente microsoft compra
100 millones de dólares en acciones de
ibm puede resultar aún más tentador
poner este ejemplo en la categoría de
inversiones porque no hay duda de que
microsoft es una empresa y parece que
aquí está invirtiendo en otra empresa
pero una vez más microsoft no está
comprando ningún tipo de equipo físico
ni un sistema de contabilidad o algún
tipo de capital intelectual simplemente
le está comprando acciones a alguien más
no se está produciendo nada nuevo en el
país así que esto no tiene ningún
impacto una vez más quiero subrayar
estos dos últimos casos porque esto
aparece en algunos exámenes la gente
piensa oh esto parece ser una inversión
al menos en el lenguaje cotidiano y los
contabiliza aquí como inversiones
recuerda que no hay nuevo capital
microsoft no está comprando nada que le
vaya a ayudar a producir más de lo que
sea que microsoft produzca bien pasemos
al siguiente caso la administración del
seguro social de eeuu
a un pago de dos mil dólares a un
jubilado qué crees que sucede aquí
podrías caer en la tentación de pensar
que se trata de un gasto del gobierno
porque la administración del seguro
social de estados unidos está gastando
dos mil dólares pero no olvides que los
gastos del gobierno se refieren a bienes
y servicios no a una transferencia como
lo es este pago las transferencias no
representan producción para poder
contabilizar lo en el pib se
contabilizará hasta que lo gaste esa
persona en consumo por lo tanto esto no
tendrá ningún impacto otra manera
intuitiva de llegar a esta conclusión y
la hemos estado mencionando durante un
buen rato es pensar que este pago no
está produciendo nada nuevo en el país
vamos a compararlo con el siguiente caso
la administración del seguro social de
eeuu compra un nuevo sistema de
contabilidad en este caso el gobierno
está comprando un bien o servicio
incluso puede ser una combinación de
ambos es posible que tenga que comprar
algunas computadoras y programas
informáticos además de contratar
los expertos para implementar el nuevo
sistema entonces el gobierno está
pagando por bienes y servicios en este
caso la categoría gastos del gobierno
aumentará en cualquiera que sea la
cantidad que gaste supongamos que
también gasta un millón de dólares por
lo tanto la categoría gastos del
gobierno aumentará en un millón de
dólares porque es un gasto en bienes y
servicios debido a ello el pib aumentará
en un millón de dólares
espero que hayas disfrutado este vídeo
hasta la próxima